You got to come over the top.
Keep them moving over the top. Enter.
You get one step in behind them and then
the other foot.
One step.
Come this way.
Okay,
Chris,
did you see that extra step you took?
Yeah. Okay. So, I wasn't even touching
him when we took that step. And we're We
don't do that. So, we're used to I was
supposed to go around my no, but we
don't do that. Okay. All All you do is
you keep the initial movement. Okay. So,
try it again.
Always
releasing tension, feeling their center,
moving their center, obeying the
yin-yang grid,
spiral rotating the whole pairing.
You You got to get used to this, Angela.
Yeah. We're not entering past them. We
enter around them.
Change partners.
And then Nag decides when you get out of
the technique again.
Try to keep it moving.
Keep them moving. Keep them moving. You
lady got to obey the yinyang rules on
the grid.
Get to that back like you were going to
choke him. Think about that.
See, he's got to get past you.
Get to the back like you're going to
choke him.
Move him past you. Keep moving.
Get to the back.
Okay. Now, again, as you're as you're
doing this, you're you're deciding. So,
he's barely pushing. I didn't have to do
anything. He pushes a lot. I can't
handle it. You move him. Okay. Or you
just started earlier. It's fine. But no
more. No more this. No more that. Right.
No more this. Okay. Let's go.
Get behind like you're going to choke
him.
Okay.
That's better. Yes.
Yes. John
got to load everything properly the
whole time.
bring it in there more.
I I would do the same thing. Try to keep
bringing it around until
nice and
So as as you as you watch me in the
technique even even at this low level
um I am some of you come here you see
I'm not here
doing these things or anything because
that that that might not be it you know
what I
and they kind of slump down like that. I
have to come around and hit them in the
face because they sat up on them on the
technique. Okay, so it's not a one and
done where I have to just do that. And
if I task myself with the ground vector,
I'll always
clean up the last stance. Hang out there
for a while.
That's where that was filling up.
Yes.
Hurry up. You're missing.
I'm kidding. How you feel?
I'm trying to
Yes. Yes.
Yes.
You got to find the space and not create
yawn.
Okay. So, for those who the footwork,
we've missed it long enough.
It's basically like if I go here,
you see it's
just we're here.
That's all we're doing. Okay. So, we No
one does like that. You get out of here
and start taking. It's just behind him.
Just says not here. It says here.
Okay.
Yes.
On the top now. Now we got to get it all
together.
Now turn them around the leg.
[Music]
So there there is a sense of when I come
in this way, it's not that I'm here and
then come there. Okay, it's this.
So if you look at the angle that this
going this way, not this way. Then I try
to load it. You get it? It's going this
way.
Okay.
Just like the other one. It's more like
you actually got.
Yes. And then breathe out. Lay down
with no need. Just enter.
[Music]
Yes, we got
We'll have to add that to the
Remember
how she did not
this
Yeah.
Let's uh let's go back a little bit.
Okay. He's just standing still.
Let's separate the legs a little. Okay.
And I'm going to come from this angle
going that way. You guys see that? Okay.
We can do it with a yu.
You just see how that alone lifts the
leg. Okay.
Same thing. You'll see me ground
move.
Just need the foot to come up. Okay, try
that.
Just stand like this, kid.
And you're going from two to four.
Open your legs more so we don't hook
your other foot.
Open your legs more.
Don't need to pulse.
No, don't do anything extra cuz anything
you do extra here takes away from what
you're doing up top, right? So, don't do
anything what we but what we said a
yubashi. That's all we're doing.
and change her first.
Separate your feet more so we don't hook
your ankle.
Don't expect that to fall if we don't
have all the forces here for us to fall.
All we are doing is lifting the foot.
[Music]
Don't push him. Don't
actually
[Music]
takes
him
not getting impacted.
Okay. Avoid the upper body. Move into
the space.
better. And then go round the back foot.
Don't let it slide in.
Everyone hang out with Zin at the end.
[Music]
Try not to bump the hips like all that
training we did.
Okay, next one.
We'll just give a slight lean. We'll
maybe put this on your head. Okay,
just a slight lean and we'll do it
again. You will have more room now
because his body is out of the way.
Okay, but the idea is the same. So my
body will go here.
Same goal only. Lift his foot. Okay,
good.
Riovis
is the slight tilt backwards. Slide
shift.
Your body goes in front of his body.
Separate your feet.
Exhaust in at the end. Make sure we're
releasing, not flexing.
Stay in that last stance.
Everything drop.
It's 6040 though. 60% of the weight is
on the back foot.
6040, not 50/50
here. I think he's on the wrong side.
Start with one side and go down the
diagonal. So, get in position. I'll
start you. Okay. So, come over here to
8:00
and go to 2:00. You're on his left leg.
Okay. Keep training.
Get off your heels.
Separate his feet a little more so you
don't.
Okay.
So, he's in that stance and I'm going to
as it lightens, it will lighten because
as the foot comes up, don't shove it
over. It gets a slinky effect. So, I'm
just doing
[Music]
Okay, try again. Don't try to find the
ball. Just be thrown. Straight your head
off the mat. Keep your body taut. Don't
Don't go unconscious and fall like a
sack of potatoes. You still have to keep
your body taut. Just like on the regular
Kenny, right? No. Every if you're doing
this one, even this one, this part is
taunt. No one falls like that. Okay.
So, try it again.
[Music]
Just do it.
Just do it. Okay.
days on on that me
get your weight 60
and off your heels.
My arm doesn't move.
Got to keep the You got to keep the
pressure. The pressure
the two pressures are working with each
other. Okay.
Okay.
You have to feel that you still have the
center. In other words, okay.
See, it gets off the top
pressure.
Keep the pressure. Yes. You should feel
the friction still.
You're going to come under his arm.
Yes.
Feel the pressure, the friction. You
want to feel the friction on the That's
better.
your back, your chest is
you're going to feel the the pressure.
Okay?
So, not just bending you over my leg.
Okay? Between the two, I feel your
center. So, see how we're locked right
there? Like over here, not locked. Even
deeper here, but different angle. Always
feeling your center.
there.
Then he falls like a lever. Just the top
hand is connected to the center and the
leg is connected to the center. It's not
that I'm here cuz he'll just bend. Okay?
And I want him to lever through space.
Okay?
Got to stay present. The whole technique
weird like that.
I'll try I'll try explaining it another
way.
Okay. So, I have a pressure here on the
chest. Correct. So, it of course can
push back, but it needs to move the
center back. So, I'm not I'm not up here
when I'm when I'm pushing here. I'm push
in the center.
Likewise, I can I can push over here.
That's incorrect. I move the center.
That's what I'm doing. It's just being
done with here. But I can also add by
I'm going to lift the center ever so
slightly. So, not this direction, but
the friction is up. That little bit is
in the technique. Okay. So, this arm is
there.
and between the two legs and all this
set that's going to be here. You get him
in what I call the body triangle. He's
trying to fall out of it and I just have
to keep it. So there's our stay. Okay.
Stay where you are. And you'll feel that
there's a kind of kind of resistance
towards trying to get out. So if I'm
here, you can slide out.
I'm here like this. I match these these
pressures and he tries to get out.
There's a little resistance to that and
that's what is being used to throw him.
Okay, you got it. As opposed to just two
independent forces and I'm doing tossy
tur. Okay.
Feel it.
This is nap.
She likes to
you keep that friction the whole way
down. They fall out of it. Not you open
it up.
Yes.
Yes. Much better.
Two independent forces
energy came out that way
to
feel the lateral friction. Yes.
So here is that there's no way you can
do this with your arm staying still.
You see because as as this gets
displaced, this has to keep a fine
pressure so that you get that that body
triangle. Okay. So here it's clearly
off. You can go out that way. Go out
that way.
back in. I get these pressures there.
You feel a little friction there, but
that tells me that I I have the center.
And I'll keep moving these forces ever
so slowly.
And he turns into that lever. It doesn't
have nothing to do with speed or
anything. Okay. All right. Try it again.
Excellent.
Okay.
I know it. It's like I know it's gone.
I would have just failed at that
lateral friction.
The arm has to move to the lower right
corner. Same side. Do it again.
Yes.
Arm has to keep moving.
Your arm has to go back. Yes.
Cuz he's going to rotate around you.
Your arm has to rotate around
too. Down. One more.
Thank you again.
Yes.
[Music]
Don't go on your heels though. Yes.
Yes.
That foot energy will come out. Energy
comes out. The friction will come off.
Down. Not back. It's got back and down
here. Taste the friction.
[Music]
Enter.
Got a base.
Keep your arch up.
Okay.
Okay. So, we'll just have his arm here.
I'll move it out of the way and come in.
Okay, try it.
Get get behind you anyway.
[Music]
You can go slow. Remember I told you
about
the arm
friction, not the pushing of
[Music]
your weight onto that front leg.
Better. Good. Follow it. Follow it with
your arm more, Ryan. All the way. Follow
it with your arm more.
Put your arm there.
The tension in the glutes is making you
step.
Keep the arch
burners.
Uh, this drill is not the slow,
methodical one. I I I can go smooth and
slowly, but I'm not going to stop and
get in there. Just you go.
However slow you go, but no stopping.
Okay, good.
More arm
[Music]
or arm friction. So you stay block
your hand has to come down. That's it.
Got to follow the arm, you guys. And you
should be able to feel when the arm got
loose. Okay. With the friction, the
upper friction of it. Okay.
Now, if you push too deep, eventually
he's going to come off.
[Applause]
The arm goes completely behind you.
Down. Follow the arm down.
matter.
[Music]
Okay.
Don't step around.
Chris, will you do our technique?
Too far back. modulated to down.
[Music]
Okay. Don't don't grab him because we're
gaming the technique. You're never going
to be standing there when we do this.
Okay. Take your own ball. Practice your
own courage.
[Music]
Don't step around.
Breathe out.
Yes.
Yes. Don't grab them. Let go. I'm self
death meditation.
not out
around you around you. So, I'll show you
what I mean. Get in this position. Okay.
And
even even here, you can be pretty
strong, right? Be strong.
There's no way. Okay. So, I can't go
out.
So, be strong again. Be strong again.
But I can go up. And when I go up, feel
the pressure on the leg. Watch. You see
where you are? Go. I go forward again.
And I'm going out. Okay. Go up again.
Look at your center.
And then I do this to the leg. And now
this got weak. Now if I go out
eventually, you're going to be ahead of
it. But if I come back towards me, it
got tight again. You see? And that's
what I'm using. Now I'm always feeling
for this friction that you're not going
that way. I'm not pushing you ahead of
me. Okay. Normal co normal pokey ho they
do. God goes away from me. This one he's
spinning around me. Okay. All right. Try
spin them around you.
The leg goes through him. He spins
around you.
leg still goes through. The leg does not
spin around him. The leg goes through.
He spins around you.
Yes.
Start paying attention to the cushion on
the elbow. Now
he has to go around you. You go through
him
meditation.
So your arm has to come. Yeah. But don't
turn your weight. Just your arms are.
Okay.
That was it.
So now there's there's no difference
wherever you're holding. Okay. So you're
going to go here.
It's the same exact thing. Okay. Try it.
I just I grab the collar. It's going to
get heavy. It's heavier and there's a
lot more slack in it. It's why I don't
use it. But you have to just work these
two together. Okay? You're like, "Oh,
that's too much. More leg." Okay, cool.
Not too much. More leg. You understand?
Okay, go. Still goes around you though.
Not back.
So she has to
[Music]
Okay.
So, if I'm here and I have this
technique, it's right there.
Okay, go.
Little different.
Not that far. Stay on his left.
Get a good base. All right.
better.
Don't feature. Pull the head.
Don't fall out of this. Don't walk out
of it.
[Music]
We're good.
Right there. When you stepped around
with your left foot, you took away
How about we bring him in?
We keep him going in.
We were going in and we
lost the body.
[Music]
Don't do anything.
Just bring it down more. He's going to
turn up and turn lower
like that.
Try to step more.
No need to turn. Just follow. You're not
falling in hot oil that you got to get
up right away. Release at the bottom.
Relax.
Down. Not this.
Down. Not this back.
Yes. You got to go around you, right?
Got to go around you. Go around.
Yes.
That's it.
[Music]
Thank you.
All right. So this is the other side of
the X pattern. The other day we did the
X pattern on the outside. This time
we're doing the X pattern on the inside.
Okay. With the base displacement.
And so again the same technique right
where uh we were doing yesterday.
This this is the way that I understand
what I'm doing is I do get that you can
use the inertia itself as your fulcrum.
Okay. And then the centrifugal force
will be your lever. I get that. Okay. Um
but again my experience is
I'm going to use that and then have a
redundancy to the architecture and
that's where the base displacement comes
in.
When we introduce that though then
people stop using the inertia and the
centrifugal energy and when you do that
then this material lever fulcrum
requires a lot more strength. Okay. Um,
I bet it is not captured on the video,
but that last wrap rep, if you were
aware,
you barely bumped his leg and it was
actually even low on his leg, not in
where we were practicing it. And that is
what that's my experience. That's quite
common. As long as everything else is
there, you can almost brush the material
fulcrum, right? the basis and it it's
good to go because it was already good
to go with the centrifugal energy and
the inertia. Okay. So, as you're getting
this phase displacement in there, you
have to again summary understand it is
redundant with the energetic fulcrum
liver. Don't don't leave it out this guy
standing still and you're going to come
in and think you're going to do that.
That's just not going to happen. We get
a lot of don't try to move, right? Okay,
they're going to try to move. So, you
have to keep them occupied in those
inertial pathways and then you just bump
and go make sure that the energy is
enough leverage for the inertia that we
send in that way. Okay,
that will really help with how much base
integrity you need. Okay, you should
always try to improve your base
integrity which is dependent upon how
much energy can you send outward. Okay,
but since we're now doing technique and
not the energetic work, you it's where
your engine is at. Okay, so if I don't
have much as much internalization ground
vectoring skill, oh, keep the inertia
going and you won't need it. Just brush
there.
Don't overemphasize that stance at the
cost of the other energetic lever.
Any questions or comments?
All right, we'll take a little break. I
said,